PROFESSOR: The isoclines applet.
Let's explore
graphs of solutions
of differential equations using
direction fields and isoclines.
The first thing to do
is to choose an equation
from the pull-down menu here.
And for this
demonstration, I will
choose the
differential equation y
prime equals y squared minus x.
In the window at left, you
can see the direction or slope
field drawn.
This is a representation of
the differential equation.
When I move the cursor
over this window,
a readout of the x-
and y-coordinates
shows up on the right-hand
side of the screen.
This is very useful in
making measurements.
If I click on the
graphing window,
the solution through the point
that I've clicked on is drawn.
This is an interesting
function, probably one
you've never seen before.
Certainly, it's not an
elementary function.
Clicking some more points
makes more solutions appear.
In fact, every
point on this plane
has exactly one
solution through it.
This is the meaning of the
existence and uniqueness
theorem for
differential equations.
Now, let's clear the solutions
using this button down here,
Clear Solutions button.
You see a blank screen again.
You can control how the slope
field looks by using this Slope
Field toggle here.
You can make them
blank, or bright
for a display, for example.
Or the way it was originally.
And I think I'm going to
turn it off altogether,
so now we're faced
with a blank screen.
Now, how would you go about
drawing some solutions
to this differential
equation by hand just knowing
the differential equation
and this blank screen?
Well, isoclines give you
a good way of doing this,
and they reveal things about
the qualitative behavior
of the differential
equation as well.
An isocline is the subset
of the plane where the slope
field takes on a given value.
I can choose that value,
m, using this slider here.
And when I click
here and move this,
the isocline with
the given value of m
is drawn in yellow
on the screen.
And you can see the value of
the slope field drawn as well.
So here is the value is
1, and the slope field
is given by little intervals
of value 1, of slope 1.
I can choose that value
using the slider marked m.
If I click on the
handle and drag it,
you see the isocline for
the corresponding value
of m drawn on the screen.
And on the isocline is also
drawn the direction fields.
So when m is 2, the
direction field has slope 2.
And when I drag the
slider back down to 0,
the isocline value 0 has a
horizontal direction field
marked along it.
Each one of these
is a curve where
y squared minus x equals m,
or x equals y squared minus m.
This is a parabola
lying on its side
with the vertex at
x equals negative m.
Let's draw the isocline
for value 1, for example.
I've now released the
mouse key, and the isocline
is left behind.
And I can easily draw
in some other isoclines
as well by clicking on
different values of m
and releasing the mouse key.
So once you've drawn several of
these isoclines on the plane,
it's pretty easy to envision
what the solutions will
look like to this curve.
You just have to thread your way
along the part of the direction
field that you've drawn.
I can check that by
clicking on the screen
and drawing a solution in.
This is quite easy
to do by hand.
It's easy to draw the
isoclines and then
sketch a solution accordingly.
But you can see other things
as well from isoclines.
I'm going to clear all of
these and redraw the m equals
0 isocline on the screen.
And I think I'm going to
redraw the slope field as well.
Now, critical
points of a function
occur where the
derivative is equal to 0.
And the derivative is exactly
what we know about the solution
to a differential equation.
So the critical points,
the minima or maxima
of solutions to this
differential equation,
occur when the solution crosses
the m equals 0 isocline, also
known as the nullcline.
All maxima and minima of
solutions to this differential
equation occur along this
particular yellow parabola.
I can check that by
drawing in some solutions,
and you can see that these
functions have maxima which
occur just along that parabola.
If the solutions
miss the parabola,
they don't have any
critical points.
Another thing you can
see from this picture
is that apparently
many of the solutions
to this differential
equation cluster
near to this branch
of the nullcline.
And maybe we can see why this
is using the isocline picture.
I'm going to clear the solutions
now to make the picture clearer
and draw in one more
isocline, namely
the m equals minus 1 isocline.
Now, suppose that a solution
finds itself below the m
equals minus 1 isocline.
So it's in here somewhere.
Can it ever cross the m
equals minus 1 isocline?
Once it's below it,
can it ever cross it?
Well, it's below it.
So if it crosses the m
equals minus 1 isocline,
it must cross it
with a slope which
is bigger than the slope
of that yellow curve.
But when it crosses
it, it also has
to cross it with slope
minus 1, because this is
the m equals minus 1 isocline.
But the slope of this yellow
parabola is bigger than minus 1
along here, and so the solution
curve can never cross it.
Similarly, suppose that
you have a solution which
is above the nullcline.
Can it ever cross the nullcline?
Well, if it crosses
the nullcline,
it must cross it from above,
so when it crosses it,
its slope must be less than the
slope of the nullcline, which
is negative as you can see.
But when the solution
crosses the nullcline,
it must cross it with slope 0.
And so, that can't happen.
And so you see, if a solution
is between those two isoclines,
then it stays between
them forever more.
It's trapped between them.
This is called a funnel.
It's trapped between
these two things,
and gets closer and closer,
because these two isoclines
become asymptotic
as x gets large.
These are called fences as well.
Once a solution is in
here, it can't cross
either of these two fences.
This let's us estimate the
value of solutions for large x.
These solutions,
anyway, for large x.
For example, if x
is equal to 100,
the solution has to be
bigger than the value
of this parabola, which is minus
10, and less than the value
along this parabola, which is
minus the square root of 99.
So you get a very good
estimate for the value
of solutions for large x from
these kinds of considerations.
One more thing you can see
from this applet is this.
If a solution is well
above the nullcline,
it gets caught in
this powerful updraft
and goes off to infinity.
In fact, all these
solutions become tangent
to vertical lines.
They don't continue
for all large x.
They blow up in finite time.
On the other hand, if you're
just a little bit smaller
than these solutions,
then you get
solutions which
cross the nullcline,
get trapped into
this parabolic region
and fall down in between
our funnel, down here,
and so become asymptotic to
minus the square root of x
when x gets large.
There's just one
solution which doesn't
do either of these very
different behaviors,
and it's right along here.
It becomes asymptotic
to the positive branch
of the parabola, and
every solution above it
blows up in finite time,
and every solution below it
falls down and becomes
asymptotic to minus
the square root of x.
This special solution-- which
doesn't do either of those two
behaviors, but
continues to exist
for all positive
values of x and become
asymptotic to the
square root of x-- this
is called the separatrix.
It separates solutions showing
two very different types
of behavior, the ones that fall
down and the ones that blow up.
Well, these are just
a few of the things
you can understand
using this applet.
Play with different menu items.
Open a copy of this applet
in your browser window.
Play with some other menu items.
Maybe the default item
at the bottom of this
pull down menu down here.
Are there funnels?
Are there separatrices?
What happens to solutions as x
goes to minus infinity rather
than x equals plus infinity?
Where are the critical points
of solutions of this equation?